good afternoon welcome to e livestream
with Grand Master Thomas Cola from
Bulgaria
so get your challenges in right now and
try your luck against the Grandmaster so
here we go okay let's slaughter the
slaughterhouse-five all right good luck
okay make your move
well wait too long we'll just the
boredom like five ten more seconds and
the clock is not moving right cuz he has
so he has until he hasn't made a move so
just XML just great yep let's go to
another challenge yep all right Adrian
66 77 all right here we go
all right remember to get those
challenges in so we can so we have a
grandmaster play
so what opening was out no it was a
respect for the system of something like
a it's called a forest right
yes really good Bishop do you want to
trade yeah
[Music]
you know time to pressure washer
[Music]
interesting case we got the middle lock
down pretty good you dr. chi sent her
pawns there
so as you can see Grandmaster coleauxv
as a Rams fan and we're not gonna we're
not gonna blame them for that you know
at that C file lockdown
he's hanging in there
now I can take
[Music]
and you're up on time too so he's only
got 40 seconds left I said doesn't seem
to make much count to play good spiteful
stop that right there let's create a
little bit of twist like rook takes on
d5 I'm just in case he doesn't see it
[ __ ] does he face any threat I don't
see maybe
maybe
let's see you know what's happening here
you're crushing on that's what's
happening
yeah he'll a seven seconds learn about
small attack all right well he resigned
all right good job little good game okay
push killed oh yes yes okay so let's see
three minutes okay because last time he
didn't house why he'll play this time
why are you chanting slaughterhouse well
obviously baby say he's having some
technical difficulties oh he played well
he played there you go
I'll hit rematch fun there you go it's
thinking alright alright now you're
playing he's pretty high rated
alright see what can we say here
Cheers first London okay
he said you played the reverse London in
the last game that man it's cold
[Music]
we managed to grab the center again I
wish I could grab the center like that
on my games I think I can clear this
thing I'm not 100% sure but I think I
can play fine that's right I kind of
think I can
[Music]
okay now let's see
it has to be some pressure a lot of
pressure I guess hey the power structure
has to be important they used to tell me
that in school the part structure was
important yes I mean this is what they
they were teaching me
[Music]
not like 9h for Queen age 695 if it's
what you like Queen age six night age
495 know if it's possible well okay it's
kind of a reluctant to give me that
because we will see maybe who captain
he's played before cooperative sometimes
it'll cooperate right master sometimes
they okay yes sometimes they don't
cooperate let's see how you defend the
pole
you can find a way to do it then Bishop
b4 Sam Bishop it should be okay b6 is a
little bit embarrassing here I have to
plate I mean I understand it well III
think if they can check my thin one oh
yeah do you know you have to take what
they get if you don't think what they've
you know still threatening visually for
at least you know and having like so
Luke help is going to say threat but
it's not going to happen long ago okay
all right that's game good game good
game good slaughterhouse okay now play
somebody else are you gonna senior bro
three minutes okay this one yeah playing
there you go alright
I can't even pronounce his name it's a
lot of it's a lot of adjectives a lot of
a lot of consonants they're not too many
vowels yeah these people challenge they
don't want to move in five seconds five
okay there you go yes we have some
comments in Bulgarian here yes yes well
they see I don't know what they're
saying
oh that's Greek excuse me I don't wanna
go everyone distract you all right okay
what do you 6 millimeter son India on
YouTube it Kingdom Australia play the
Kings Indian okay I'm playing a solid
system which I haven't played for all
the time but let's see how it is
hmm there is such a move it was in
silence in the house hey what's up I saw
you come in all right okay okay
Subic is waiting all right sue look
we're gonna get to you next
all right next to make the move sound
okay
Danny Machuca I think you're saying they
don't like the sound wave sound I think
what they played his I remember a long
time ago was like a dubious take of a
poem but okay this is what I remember
from probably 20 years ago really in
this position yeah I mean I used to play
before people and okay this sounds he
said I dislike the move sound so I just
heard that seems like I'm watching a
Super Mario I kind of like them do you
like them all right I think we I think
we should say more move or move I guess
maybe it's not bad because a bishop a
fighter so maybe I'm not getting the
total for a second I thought his Queen
was hanging but yeah I don't feel like
cooking I'm going to sacrifice in
exchange just in case you see
maybe it's not bad I told the home winos
okay it was Bishop take on f6 yeah just
take mystics was winning
the first Hillstrom very different
and yes some compensation make maybe not
that special
okay this is probably dubious though
yeah I'm trying to get the Queen on the
long table know who's wasting time which
is but already in the whole line after
keep like Bishop has to build to take on
f6 he takes take take and his roster
yeah I mean I just yeah you have to play
ok this going to follow this undefeated
so far today
oh he's undefeated yes absolutely
absolutely ok now this move I don't see
don't want to trade Queens I would
imagine say this move so I'm going to
that was a good move I keep missing some
stuff which is not very good but okay
well you're getting your hang in the
back of the computer so yeah now for
example yeah he's trying to put item in
the same thing and we're going to repeat
a little bit sure for him to waste a
little bit of time okay together but
this okay
No
can I find something better probably I
can alright on this move I could have
played up audible blast with it but now
if the place musics are not going to
there's a three role repetition on the
board baby he didn't claim it I'm not
going to play no I'm going to play
something else
I'm not very sure how is this more but
was disposition because he doesn't have
much time so that's why I'm not very
keen to to make here to finish the game
okay he is hanging in there with you
though yeah he is
yes well there we go got something going
now
good job what a game what a gig that was
incredible that was incredible no I was
great that was great
Oh next time if you could play Subic
says he's been waiting a long time next
time all right
is that good
so it's hard to believe
mr. simpleton what did you miss me for
[Music]
like a mr. cool so he misty for didn't
he yeah because he could have forked you
right yeah yeah that's what happens in
these time pressure games you miss moves
you would normally miss
now I have to play a little bit
faster
so it something as you to confirm that
you want to win a Raider
okay it's pretty even game here and
you're down a little time then I will go
up to Boston got a little time
Oh his Potter's pin isn't
what is this I can't believe this is
this good
that's gonna do it nothing you can do
all right good game pong best all right
who was the know to play the top guy
play this good yeah yeah cuz they'd
really know longest the people on top of
been waiting longest he's waiting now
he's not playing
okay all right
alright bye alright top of the list
there you go this face
[Music]
Grandmaster Cola is still undefeated
undefeated well this should be dubious
I have this feeling this should be
mm-hmm this is real into this hold me
prove it
[Music]
hmm
this
very powerful a knight c6 but that's why
I'm an amateur now plan I think what I'm
trying that to create him even more weak
spots okay this this is going to be
followed by this one
and this seems like a [ __ ] for him yes
yes just in case if he takes he's gonna
hang his rook what we didn't pick up
with 1/4 balls just in case
it's not bad
it does always helps to have a couple of
good boys know
so if you hit up all those have to
defendant it's always good good strategy
defend those and those past pounds right
something
all right get those challenges in
no this one is a bit more smaller
because it's on five minutes right
well three minutes maybe gives more
dynamics I haven't played for a long
time please but okay now how do we need
a strategy there let's see well I mean
want to play King be 16
becoming a little bit here some twisting
hmm he has some threats going yeah
don't try to keep
maybe not very good but ok it's ok ok
this is because it's defended right he
didn't realize it was defended I think
he he realise your Bishop was defending
now you're crushing him and our paper
should be three and it seems like
everything
unbelievable hey come up with these
rules it's really see the board just
despair sadness you seen your a board
one good game senior and just go from
the top because people are waiting yeah
yes Blanca yes five minutes all three
years whatever you want today
let's cover Lucy Lewis against good luck
he plays here he does challenge all the
time
Capablanca century does a challenge all
the time Ryan Chester's in the house
club manager Oh staff tournament is
today here deal Chess Club the pizza
ride yet
I would have to be departing as co-host
soon here because the staff tournament
is starting soon so won't be on your own
for a minute you can handle it I know
you can handle it mm-hmm yeah all right
those challenges in and good luck
everybody all right Jim
you're on your own for a minute
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
there you go hmm oh yeah you get to the
play-doh okay
ah who are you playing with $1,900
he's not much of a friend of enemies
what opening is this Evans competent oh
the abysses of it all so romantic
yeah is it is the Evans gambit a bad
opening or so there was an interesting
one though that it's gonna be played let
me see I think
you were talking about the outposts on
f4 is that where your queen of 600 Queen
f6 and lat Knight f4 or oh you're just
gonna attack the pin piece okay and what
about Bishop e2 I'm going to exchange I
give an extra pawn so I'm going to
exchange this 23 where I decide and then
okay that's queen of sexual theater then
I don't seem to like now okay this one
is hanging sometimes which is which was
my idea so I'm not going now to get the
visual you can wait for some trick to
open up on the beach yes yeah okay okay
no he's not kidding but okay surprise on
the dark squares because okay when the
main defender is defending on the dark
squares it has to be something well this
can be exchanged now although why take
change the piece which is really not
interested
let's keep well if we trade it does d4
hang yes but I'd like to keep our yields
like even more now and even more you
understand no I can take it immunity
because okay night if sake 96 is at
right now so I can defend yeah I'm gonna
take because I win attention all taken
now 95 is a Titan that okay in this
exchange of two moves I think my move is
more your sake
this is seems okay but it's not
[Music]
this is true everything is for now let's
leave this night without many squares
and okay with this outpost here probably
should be enough well you can pretend
that there is compensation but nobody's
going to believe
thirty-five I can play here five
interesting because I think that he's
becoming a little bit too you know
okay now once oh wow what is this okay
no no because with this guy with two
times we let him play and then he was
slow so let's get okay somebody with
more oh it's a good discover attack
I didn't mean took me a second okay
Buddha is very strong no I just want I
played was a guy if I'm you know it was
the only draw but he played okay he
played okay and he told me that he was a
place Kia frequently he wanted to blow
okay yeah blowing a century something no
God Blanc a century know his name okay
yeah I mean I know plays on the stream a
lot
you played to be an Olympic the line of
the newspaper maybe we'll play the first
one that I saw it I saw a new book on
this gambit by every man chess it's the
first time I've seen the gambit though
it's it's a sound gambit okay this I
don't know this I have serious doubts a
disabled man I don't know what is the
point
yeah that's a great discovery - -
Fairweather says I was a great discover
attack and it truly was and it was
prepare to g4 yeah hey you knew that was
happening yeah yeah yeah this takes one
f6 this guy is playing there that what
is happening here why are you are giving
your bishops I mean you are the one who
sacrificed material not me oh that's the
end of the game a little bit yeah that's
the end of the game
Oh buddy sg5 you play fine butters - I
mean I can play in juicy yeah you see I
wonder if he saw e5 more enough he just
did somebody with more writing VN oh
yeah yeah I played yeah well if you want
to play a GM just go to light chests and
challenged us and I'll find the link
right now okay G for you see Oh G for
interesting opening but I know I
disguise for my early years yeah okay
they played this one against me when I
was a kid okay but what rating were your
opponents when they played this remember
something sometimes they they play this
okay let's see now
okay what kills me maybe he's playing
simply bad yeah
trying to make Queen b6 you're right
okay now he's letting look now you can
just do it that's why cuz it at this
night I don't seem to have too many
great idea page one Queen takes on a
loop yeah right no no but the good thing
is it y'all if you play
night night be one is talking so we have
to play queens you on the end offering
an end game right right what he saw is a
knife and game he's gonna resign
complaints no now you have a slight
advantage so okay now I'm going to play
positionally we likes apiece yeah okay
yeah I guess g4 didn't work out and you
play bad after that as well easy game
just trying to press you
are you gonna cast it you're not gonna
Castle kingside though you're just gonna
remain uncatted yeah oh no no no see I'm
going no I'm trying to push the d4
Oh in case I don't know why he's pushing
these pawns I mean he's attacking me
even in the in the middle game but now
is next to be frightened
yeah everybody has to pretend attack you
right otherwise oh yeah I mean great you
guys will try something but wait I think
well I like which one I can even play
King dead King King c7 Oh No Winky out
now it's like probably I'm going to
attack nope not King oh okay I'm going I
can pick up this pawn if I want with the
h6 and then g6 take take 97 what about
night h4 and Bishop g4 and then straight
the pieces
yeah I mean we take the piece and you
have the center and just wow this is
what is that this is good that's a
second okay he's attacking you okay I
forgot work oh yeah okay no that's too
much
even he'll resign yeah is there somebody
who wants to play and let's do some
people on the top are usually waiting
too long yeah yeah pumpkin well not on
the very yeah oh yeah Justin yet we'll
just to let everyone play they've been
waiting in the queue longer looking
usually huh she going well I can play
with t4 but that's a fine goal today we
have about the romantic period of chess
oh you okay so with this team the only
person I know who plays this [ __ ] Goran
is is fine gold or at least when he's
not seriously rich Moser is not the not
in serious reverse ultimately I yeah
okay Jesus this is nice maybe too
this might be fighting this old and any
of his moves
I am gonna justify his face before he
played Bishop d7 9b v didn't work
oh okay just okay okay yeah interesting
oh yeah that's a yeah I'm going to put
taller piece in the center
uh-huh I guess doesn't get much here do
wow that's then you see I've got Center
okay yeah if he's weakening I'm going to
put a knife there soon
you know no he had 95 from 95 this move
oh yeah and nightly let's see let's see
where the NIT this night from before is
going because ok is gonna play a take
the bishop but after that where it's
going right I mean my Bishop is no
better place to be ok this is your
Bishop only one is even better
I'll play around here just to question
what about you threatening me five so he
has to play e5 er I can take white boy
oh now I wanted to play e5 but I mean
maybe maybe I can't even wait a little
bit because he sure seems so bad I'm not
going to play Bishop h6 yes I want him
to to show some moves because he's
basically not doing anything
I also queena for sometimes can make
it's very interesting this this is
nothing because okay the knife goes
[Music]
mmm keeps thinking right
okay this is probably not sustainable
position
after move like t68 efficient couldn't
bear this I mean everything else still
don't kill certain point but as of this
moment
okay just a free piece I just have to do
oh but he has 932 I didn't do anything
Mountain all right I'll play I think
he'll check check and check no sir
not now it's easy oh yeah now it's now
he just adjust that same biofuels with a
guy since you often get extra pieces it
seems on the stream
yeah okay this
how are you gonna get your Bishop on b1
back into the game
what's his I'm going to become checkmate
I think I'm going to play here and then
f4 f5 is gonna have is gonna just trade
no than theirs that's yeah even better
am I blind well it doesn't matter
Wow just gonna take that pawn and okay
all right great
I put this button I'll okay what's
happened okay I can walk yeah it's a
good tactic yeah there we gonna take his
cleaner you can look for a checkmate
no I'm gonna its I want to be practical
No
and then to play this to have with the
tempo know if he moves the rook to pin
me for example
oh that's a good idea good idea he was
everything he was breathing oh good game
good game that was yeah you think he was
at the top or no - or something oh yeah
the top yeah just because they were
they've been waiting a while
oh you look pretty for I cannot please
let's play yes I mean we're he's kind of
on the lower side so open maybe so Sarah
gambit you want to play against him yeah
yeah just have fun
[Music]
yeah okay I really can't but well you
could play the Scotch camp it yeah right
you could yeah just Bishop c4 right yeah
okay good game Keaton GG oh you wanted
scourge gambit it's good yeah yeah all
right yeah
many kids they won one girl went to
chess camp she plays she plays this
opening she played the Scottie - can I
explain - to hunt coconuts what is best
I hear them the main thing she always
does take with you - Bishop take on f7
quindi right yeah right right yes Knight
of 6 we're into the main line of the of
the Italian so after Knight f6 as if
you've played the Italian c3 Knight f6
d4 it takes given for the main line of
detail right but or it cost him it was
team one one minute which probably is a
little bit too much ok this move is
possible probably not very good but I'm
going to catch on nice and safe well
this I'm going to
and I'm going to pick up the center
I hope so after queen g6 you're gonna
yes I'm going to take on only seven I
think and take Wendy 400k very sick but
maybe okay maybe not the best look why
not it's just solid solid advantage oh
yeah
okay no exams
now what do we do
he's going to play an extra let's
include this one just in case
please now we have the 94 sometimes with
the tempo do I need to move this right
this 95 worth anything is that improving
or just getting a buy d6 later what is
black playing here is really about 95 or
proof using Gentle I'm not very
practical here I'm going to put this in
the center where is my time out and then
play Queen t3 and then just put out the
rock and will find that just super using
the same time is very practical play
should have freed the Queen's Bishop oh
yeah he sure I did right now open this
is exactly what I was waiting this is
great yeah the good idea of the piece in
the center that they have no options
well it they can learn a lot from that
because no I can't become the punished
yeah just doing nothing I guess works
sometimes
nice okay I mean for those more modified
ENC something can create you need a
little bit more time on your have to be
really a very good player so that's why
I said it okay when you itself wasting
more time just put the pieces through q1
and room d1 in most of the cases these
are not bad situation to put the piece
in the center they care about the family
and I saw even before playing a rookie
one that she wants to develop this
Bishop on g4 ana so I want to wanted to
develop my squares on Nandi phone
okay he's trying here to do somehow
create like he's not trying anything
basically
it's going to be suffering
oh this guy is also from from Bulgaria
yeah luckily for what he's doing right
so much more to us in chat a second ago
that's so fleecy so there it goes and
you you are always a thief I've player
please play okay but we do my play all
right okay this is a well-known okay
this Wow oh he thought he will take on
c3 right yeah and then just trade all
right no I just and develop your stuff
master like no because the endgame is
good not so sure so I thought that this
was okay I did
why not always equal to here well I
think the poem can be taken if you a
fake have to be honest no wow
but playing in it I'm not going a little
brave look no I mean I can take it it's
a free poem and I mean that the rookie
one thing doesn't that nothing no and
here I think I can take it
no I'm not sure that he cares but okay
III playing focus on super safe you know
and then I block and I have an extra
piece I mean okay so you play a five and
this is the end of the game
I mean after he 595 take win takes 27
which is not the only move
but they both win say FY 500 again I
mean keep right extra piece and the
pollution is blocked no I mean he
doesn't have even a trace of duty
well he's trying to get something out of
that that chad is asking what is your
feed a rating right now five thirty nine
twenty five thirty nine twenty five you
know for sometimes so it's not really
[Music]
okay so what's his doing here so really
don't know you the purpose is lost
moment
so does he have a pole no no no but I
kept thinking too much no okay the the
people would like to see a budapest
gambit oh I don't know I mean it's not
up to me I mean they've only one game
they play d4 against me yes
no the budapest gambit is is what is
that yeah that's d4 Knight to 1645 ah
okay okay I mean
yeah
you're not gonna take on be to just
develop your stuff very practical play I
feel like I could learn a lot from just
keeping it simple
no I have second yeah but just but look
at me just I mean why not put some why
not put some stuff in there oh okay
maybe you'll play d5 Bishop c5 well no
let's see it right now same thing no
actually not okay it's to Bishop c5 okay
let's I can play this on d5 I kept
Bishop on c5 now I cleared this for you
now I'm not going to play any more here
biggest 95 number 94 all right now I'm
going to push b5e for some very
practical player he's not doing much
more I always want to I have night Nyjah
phone
yeah I mean I don't see if he's
threatening something maybe yeah maybe
don't
well let's not kid ourselves
I am the one with extra business not you
this is too much what is this
keeps giving me something it's a very
generous person and it trade and okay
that's it that's the end of the game
Oh that surprised me
doesn't it I thought maybe we'll play 97
to to e5 to d3
well but qu doesn't go through anything
okay it doesn't matter okay I'm chosen
12 minutes just getting on bowling nice
simple chess not simple with strong if
you want store to make me a passport go
you would take back with your pawn yeah
yeah and get a passport
Oh interesting okay no no you would tape
the rock open oh this old five minute um
yeah that's nice 1 5 2 's a little slow
let's just do a 5 yeah yeah
okay say forget the Budapest play the
Benoni well no one's playing d4 against
yes I can play the blue okay now we can
play the Benoni unless they play the
London oh yeah like blame or like usual
things yeah this is rare no that's a
strange that's what time control yeah
we're looking for three two or five
minutes later you know yeah Mohammad the
pre move kind of cost you the game sadly
if you'd like to reach Alan Jess you go
ahead yeah so what's happened you're
keeping your free pawn I guess no I can
play this okay
yeah you played in the opening a three
so you still keep on yeah I mean then
okay I'll try to keep the phone yeah
if you play safe or at least
okay take with a bishop not the only
movement why not
I have a feeling that this guy will play
d5 you should be sir I know those are
wrong you're just gonna block it the
bond people take alone so no cu5 is
quite good
well now you can try d5 yeah yeah yeah
play your Poupon no I'm you know I'm
just takin d5 it's no problem and then I
can choose to play like 95 of the take
95 degree takes meself next opponent
still not not clear why you know yeah
well our played c5 sooner or later but
we will see what is the best moment well
this seems like not a bad one so so
Knight b6 wasn't worth the blockade that
define possibility and then c5 if I very
quickly to undermine these pawns no
because you I track here not to Castle
early no because then he can have some
kind of imaginary oh he doesn't get
because he doesn't have a dark square
Bishop here I need the Casso I mean I
have a pair of Bishops and his Santa is
falling apart so there's a lot of ways
to a plane that yeah so you're saying
tips on improvement what do you think
people should do to improve invest more
times in chess I mean this may sound
like a very standard but it's it's true
you have to to give it time because it's
a complex game it's a rather interesting
one but you know you need to spend hours
it's not like a joke they say that the
guys who become very good time they
spend like at least 10,000 hours in
whatever area so also interests effort
so sometimes people interested well I
want to be well okay you you be but you
have to give it some time now and in for
example I work a lot with the kids and
kids have class with us in school yeah
but maybe after I think when you go home
you also have to spend at least one hour
day or like five hours a week about it
sometime at least not it's pretty you
can't just
and if you and if you have the time what
do you think you're the best method to
improve is if you're giving the time
well nowadays we have many good things
for example you have all kind of a
access to different media so you can
look at the chair calm all these best
best when they play this match is 5
minutes 3 minutes you can look at all
aspect in following that current game
yeah I mean I don't have like one
special advice but ok I try to to build
up your strength and then follow some
like basic fundamental like in every
position when you look at it the first
thing you check is can I take something
can I give check you know ok let me see
the time nothing to miss some things
which which is a little bit that's why
mr. TT
let's see some trick
who does rook bb-8 and then that they
take on e7 queen is a double tack or no
that's more because they could take on
b7 though okay but we only lost I'll
take this one ah I can give oh yeah I
just have to a little bit just to think
about the game just to find some demos
because I love this myth more gambit
yeah I used to like this myth more
gambit too until I realized I was just
down upon
[Music]
how many points like a this guy says
dear Grandmaster I'm twenty years old
and about twenty three hundred I
defeated lots of Iams and wrap it in
classical chess but in tournament chess
I play very badly and can't concentrate
I feel stressful what should I do I'll
try to work on this weaknesses like what
can I say I mean try you know just to
over overcome these nerves you have to
find first what is the reason why you
get nervous and then try to to come over
Thai I mean without knowing personally
it's difficult to say why he becomes
like nervous certain situation I mean
you have to to be more aware of the
games and what what he's doing this is
like very personal just to know why
somewhat with a good chess swing in some
moments of the game he becomes you have
to know more more details in my opinion
let's see
learners concentrate on the game just to
finish it and then okay
what's that
[Music]
it looks like we have quite a bit of
time advantage here feel pretty good
about that board anything
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah tough game it wasn't but I lost
concentration sure work these after a
rookie 70 guy a little bit was
completely we ensuring they play you
know it's difficult to hey let's see
poor cares I welcome yeah
if you want to be on it you can or if
you're just getting snacks go ahead yeah
okay yeah good good game Jeep GG seems
like people are mixed on our on whether
they like the sounds or not on the
stream here maybe maybe we'll change the
sounds if if too many people don't like
it I think a lot of people like it
though no way I missed most of this game
you're playing Paul Kara's that's the
strong player challenges is not bad at
all
what is the name of this defense yeah
well opening a little sooner it was a
closes iliyan okay this is getting it a
little bit too far but it's kind of fuse
yeah I guess he just wants to take the
pawn on on g3 and it's protected and
that's the end of his idea okay yeah
okay a lot of people seem to like it I
would love to see the Danish gambit I
will give someone in this stream a sub
okay so we need to play a Danish gambit
wafer for one of our viewers here my
friend Dennis liver who loves the Danish
gambit so we'll see how a grand master
does with it I don't know which one is
the finished image ii 4 E 5 d 4 oh yeah
but a new this is a central again oh
okay okay
okay
we had this one
okay
it's really becoming interesting let's
see
well it's gonna be hard this place whose
Stafford if no one's gonna play
interesting me okay
hi sake who's going to attack my lady oh
no he is dead okay yeah I assume this is
a game so alright no wait even you're
better than me Wow a little bit nice to
see this this night because I know
welcome to stay for some squares just in
case then I have cut along this to page
six is also not a bad idea sometimes
don't get the oil now now this chick
isn't it to become a little bit maybe
not the strategy to and then no then you
have a lot of very first chance I like
to put this Bishop on f4 because it kind
of looks fancy just does porn f4 than
porn f3 yeah oh yeah yeah well I like
like maybe it's not very good position
was to react and then you're gonna
Castle on put the rock on g8 no stupid
because now if you play 92 yeah no need
for that no only to get so fancy but
okay well so yeah okay I'm at least the
advantage of the bishop is that you can
coexist change one of them this very
different yeah okay no I still have the
right now probably forgot I can first
thing I had to pay a little bit faster
way I'm threatening he'll be g8 which is
not oh we also have Bishop to d4 d5
right yeah a lot of a lot of loose ends
okay Bishop h3 Bishop h6 oh they were
looking for I actually don't know what
this guy's suggesting
Bishop each things
oh nice okay
okay this way to play this it's playing
fast now
[Music]
after after rook takes G - Queen takes G
- bishop d5 didn't win the Queen yeah
yeah yeah everything it was this kind of
this one Oh somebody let's go to the top
yeah to the top as long as plates for
the house you want to play again
oh yeah yeah let's play them again he
asked for a rematch okay a while I don't
know come today okay okay maybe you
don't know so we really supposed to play
d5 after c6 is that why we don't see c6
as a reply I don't know maybe okay
because you've never seen C 606 Y will
kill take on c6 don't know I mean you
can play a folk are gonna complete up no
no no I mean d4 c6 and if are we
supposed to play d4 no he'll take okay
fine
I mean why why you should play why
should play d5 really interesting okay
yeah that sounds about right
no I'm just curious why d4c sixes and a
reply like was the drawback no no see
six is not all of the d-46 it's not a
bad move it's not bad my phone it's just
not a okay this this is probably not
very good
this is probably Debrecen oh oh you
didn't like that what was going oh oh
poor guy
something about the Danish
and this I feel is it it's not going to
be a very pleasant day
oh no they didn't play e5 so we couldn't
play the Danish at that time yeah so I'm
going to play here this one yeah some
special trick or you're just developing
your pieces just about okay after this I
thought that I have one trip taken t6 me
and I know with with such a bad
development this should be good man
maybe there's something even better if I
immediately looks very good also no no
it probably is very bad for him
oh yeah let's just open the board yeah
this is developer super faith of air oh
I didn't see him play I played in 96
down oh yeah this this is possible yes
but it should be matter
oh it's opening up this should be good
my describe bishop is a beast
I have high dolls and this patient came
to help
probably it can look like this I can
give you the point it's not a problem
I don't know how give you because
because it's you so if we if it takes it
you're gonna play 22 and then yeah
indeed yeah I mean I thought that taking
this is quite bad but you decided
okay now I can play this just in case
and now it's kind of a many choices many
good choices
yeah why not now I'm starting to look
takes from you 16 how nice this is not
going to end very this is like it's like
the boat into me but it is not going to
end very nice okay this is checkmate
mouch we're all way to get check it
slaughterhouse will slaughter so this
guy this guy let's do the top that there
you goddess underrated player
I got here that was a lovely checkpoint
yeah I was yeah this is the rare rarely
you can you can keep a very best range
pattern the popular shop it's a useful
you take a poll you take more control
the tax quiz and also you're threatening
immediate I mean oh he should have
played night a fade but still it's like
a completely was pollution oh yeah all
right ed Gandhi where are you yeah let's
just move on yeah must a young since
kill no no I'll do all right have every
plate yes I'm sort of on the top of the
list is this because the other one was
five minutes okay let's let's play ball
games yeah because sometimes when you
feel when you play this three minutes
game five minutes ties to feel like a
correspondent game exactly okay in the
opening
in f3
this is interesting probably not will
interested
Wow yeah what is this weird
configuration oh thank you no good mom
now the precise said yeah but good I
just look over and he's always you're
always winning a piece its pouch yeah I
think I don't think he'll play on maybe
[Music]
well in New York City they have they
have somewhat the Marshall chess club is
in New York right I'm pretty certain
Emily that's yeah even if you're a
beginner you should you should play your
local club they'll probably have other
beginners it wouldn't make sense to play
in like to travel to the tournament but
if yeah a local club is where where you
should start off
yeah for sure and yeah just do some
tactics and and you should be able to go
play in your local club yeah but do you
have to be good at chess before you go
to your club not not really I mean you
should know how to move the pieces and
you know a little bit about strategy and
yeah I mean it's you know no one's ever
really ready for their first tournament
you kind of just got to get in there and
learn by by losing your first couple
tournaments and then asking friends
asking people asking people at the Chess
Club if they can help you review your
games that would that's probably how how
we should go about that yeah
noise gonna take this piece for free I
don't think he'll defend it oh yeah
okay this
pretty much over
here when you get less time it puts you
in the right this is a good idea
yeah to alert you know a chest on top
learn that they understand we do that
okay here they take I have checking CTO
a 92
mm-hmm this guy wants to fight for sure
let's write him
take more fees I know just too much
yeah he's coming at ya all right good
game maybe maybe just two more games for
the stream and then yeah let's just do
some toys this is what yeah okay there
we go
okay that's a serious game this is a
stronger thanks for the game thank you
for the game and you see what you can do
I barely know the rules
I know mr. no need to pretend like sorry
I have to go something
anyone wants to take a bit 95 no take
[Music]
I this I think was not so much
this is just a typical Grand Prix attack
right yeah but this I think his version
is not it's not so good okay no you
don't play f5 to shut down his f5
now try to keep him not to play at five
now so before you know but you don't eat
threatening to play at five so okay I'm
going to develop my square who is
finding a way to develop your stuff
positionally I should be doing great you
the the person you'd played last so I
like play very very very slowly let me
just h five
[Music]
see
you'll play if I don't know
you have to play first
so again I see one moment which how how
is defended this problem yeah oh yeah so
weak bond anything good I don't see how
it's defending so that that's a good
point yes that's why they usually don't
push them up but I think too much they
they because I've got accustomed to to
play with the easier guys and yeah
alright we'll see I have to pay first
I don't know
critic
Oh
he's been also told that's Quinn's I
think he threw everything at you and it
didn't work in anyone yeah he's gonna
resign
as okay I was interesting let's play
with
let's see somebody on three minutes okay
Mort no no matter we play
oh yeah that's again a sign oh yeah what
we play okay
will do on the e-file to thing yes play
e5
I thought it may be okay maybe I thought
it may be mortar is the one for whom is
scanned Ami's subsea for but not public
you oh well might have been higher
no maybe not yeah cause he played d4 and
this this or this move I haven't seen in
my life no that's a shocking all the
ponies hanging okay
I can make better
okay so I saw this move we have to get
this Vichy jeath person before we do we
go off street so that's that would be
the last game we pound
[Music]
[Music]
no Bishop takes f7 95 nothing nothing
the only thing I would be concerned
you know I really always can't cover
here the line I think yeah so be Sofia
Bishop e6 would have been a worse move
because I thought it wouldn't just stop
and then no Bishop takes f7 positive I
have to finish the development in some
way and Bishop g5 he is not a problem
because you always cover the line with
something only Sigma should be sorry
okay okay
not an ID for Bishop d7 oh yeah sure
upon he can get his pawn probably play
Queen f3 I'm very sure how much will now
play d5 so I'll keep the pawn yeah why
not tell me who gives you pawn isn't
okay now I can play 96 and I can play f6
and I don't know why f6 is bad you don't
seem that but 96 seems also not bad so
this is like a question yeah which one
is better
yeah it's just so I play this one 96
maybe it's not the best no it's not the
best this is the stupid
yeah
you can play taken f4 and this is oh I
didn't plate so I can pay for yeah that
was interesting
oh yeah play this one for in the morning
over here Wow that's devotion to be on
the phone not chest stream at 4:00 in
the morning okay I'm not afraid here I
can give him the pawn and have a bishop
but I'm not going to give him the pawn
so this is another thing that I'm not
much in integrating pause I realized I
realize that you love your I've worked
in your fonts I wrote and you're gonna
keep them grabber so now I'm not going
to give you the phone because like I
said I've worked for this Bombers so
it's yours
okay I'm use g4 yeah that you can rely
that I'm always going to know you play
very practical chess it looks like for
for blitz anyway that seems to be air
motif a super nice super solid no it
should be not very difficult
okay this bond is first I'll put a look
yeah just in case and then I'll put the
ball okay just in case he blundered
have not all difficulties it looks like
it easy he's early
she doesn't have any square for this
dish any square for intestine
still no no squares
okay I missed it he has one square there
so oh that's why he played g3 no no I
missed it too this hanging the palm tree
it's still not going to be anything
I see we're saying yeah yeah take on d5
oh but it didn't do it
no because he's flagging
yeah this was not very good game better
still hey you can't burn today yeah yeah
you play solid and you convert hit the
game
okay so let's yeah we need a play no
cheats okay and and then we'll also play
Batman Begins okay
so two two games that's it then no more
even if you've been waiting forever this
is the kernel you should you should yeah
hey there yes always challenge us were
rated especially when the grandmasters
playing as we would need your points
good one I guess I missed f4
I remember one when f4 was played okay
oh you play the London yeah there was
one student I go which you know she said
before it
Charcot system and I never kept played
in my life but because she didn't want
to study alone so she only looked at
just one and she was with me so I invent
this with Bishop a4 but with different
ideas of that he became strangely super
popular that's why all right this has
been played against me check and King it
all so this is a line
yeah Rosen plays Queen p1 so he even
included some new ideas check King d1 so
calcium again so no and night yeah and
I've played again this is a normal
variation or 92 is not better than this
they're moving your kingdom no 1994 it's
not Oh
many years ago become ski no this I
think is suspicious move this is a move
Queen 84 is threatening them so now the
rookin be one if play Bishop a5 rook
shoots before because oh so what does he
need a play here well she's not this one
not that one
okay
can he play Bishop so after Queen a for
does he have bishops III know yeah and
he can't Bishop a5 so I can put before
but there was this is something this was
not good what was the reason maybe Queen
c2 first way I have to remember it'll be
played
now tightening Adrienne and also h4 with
95 is an idea before yeah
oh and then I say interesting well this
is this is maybe too much I don't
believe that this you can sacrifice can
be slight maybe a Kendall this is a seem
like it if you yeah he knows better
okay resource doing yeah okay I guess if
he could win here okay Jesus I okay but
Appa can the piece I'm nothing to you
doesn't have to convince me okay I'll
play this
yeah that looks like it's gonna take a
piece yeah no sacrifice a piece okay not
that but I'm not obliged to take it
because this piece is here to stay no so
let's play a little bit you know
activity right because she wants to give
me checkmate so let's see check is going
to standard checkmate okay that's good
way very active no 95 this what I wanted
to play no this is why I played this
move I mean it's not
yeah Emily it seems like the Danish
gambit didn't quite happen today but
maybe next time and I think it is
because he loves his pawns a lot well
now I think I'm doing Kevin I think this
Bishop is still waiting hey yeah we
already captured right what what can he
even do to get out of your attack I
don't know he's difficult
there's at 5:00 interesting it means
that you're 7 Oh probably music he
opened the phone yeah yeah in my opinion
he's already it's already over right it
should go away yeah I mean wait if he
was not hanging a piece it was still a
loss please and now with the pure idea
on before I even she's not yeah oh yeah
I mean over Kevin right all right not
bad but still not sufficient as they say
now what's the idea of this I mean I
just like it this movie okay I don't say
it it's good ok it's just solid ok have
to keep Lake Winnipeg Bishop before
everything is under control in here he
keeps with his keeps nice spending time
nice and his vision is not getting
better
that is usually oh well this I don't
believe it
because I have a queen I mean the
endgame is like kind of a better a
better one no slightly not much but
slightly tricky in game
we'd like so that means slightly lucky
but slightly better he says okay all
right and then we have to play Batman
Begins and we can end the show yeah yeah
yeah okay he says he's been he had a
reach out oh yes okay see what's
happening in the bet coffee for player
all right he's a solid game so maybe no
nobody wants to play ninja all right
I have to defend the bomb loves his
Ponce
Oh this was the idea of Jasper others
are coming after us
oh jeez okay
yeah pawn muncher says he likes pawns
also munch
he's like Ethel yeah yeah yeah I had
they're tasty but marching that it kept
this meaning because you know like
eating but with my Oh like yeah yeah so
I I have an idea then yeah because I was
not sure not I kind of thought that yeah
this is this kind of a mini okay only
for there was one problem did like g5 I
can I can close this movement never
wrong with that place known this I have
no g4 no so I I saw that I can play
and then I can follow with some called
c5 in the right moment
and before Stacey sent it
oh this is suspicious
okay
this can be very good
no meat for this movement okay but
because I want to play it c5 as soon as
possible not not that you know I need it
I can just play must be Sarah and in
this post structured very hard to
believe that he can get anything going
[Music]
I'm gonna sneak back in the control room
so industry after this game
[Music]
so you want to talk to here and just say
thanks for watching thank you thanks for
watching and hope to see you very soon
bye